since being introduced to the is a  jingoo I've been fascinated by this  sense of renewal how the architectures  rebuilt how those skills are passed on  and another aspect I found really  interesting is discovering that there's  over a hundred thousand Shinto shrines  in Japan so I set about trying to  uncover as many shrines locally as I  could and it's been a really beautiful  experience reoccurring elements like the  torii gate each one will have a certain  response to its context whether that's  which objects are the near or which bits  of nature it frames or make sacred to  each of these shrines even the tiny ones  in the middle of a neighborhood have  this feel and this sense of the place  around and it off' 'el ways of just  expressing like a connection with your  place your environment I have got more  out of seeing these informal smaller  shrines than actually the much larger  ones which is something I wouldn't have  expected to before I came here